- Hi everyone,
welcome to our Homeroom livestream
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
I'm very excited about the very relevant
guest we have today, Randi Weingarten,
president of the American
Federation of Teachers.
And before we jump into that conversation,
I encourage you to start
thinking of your questions,
put them in the message boards
on Facebook and YouTube.
But I will give my standard announcement,
a reminder to folks that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit organization.
We can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about going
to khanacademy.org/donate.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations
that have stepped up
over the last several
weeks, actually months.
When COVID picked up,
they realized that Khan Academy
was already running at
a deficit pre-COVID.
And then as you can imagine,
the traffic to our site,
we wanted to accelerate a
whole series of programs
for families and teachers.
So our deficit has only increased,
but these organizations really stepped up
and helped close some of that.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly, Novartis and
actually the Amgen Foundation.
And many of the other supporters,
both organizations,
foundations, corporations,
and individuals who make
all of this possible.
So if you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
So with that, I am
honored to invite our gu--
To introduce our guest, Randi Weingarten,
President of the American
Federation of Teachers.
Thank you so much for joining us Randi.
- Thank you, I'm honored to be with you.
And really honored that
the, whatever tropical storm
hurricane we were going through,
seems like it is passing through quickly.
So people will be safe.
- Okay (laughing) that's,
that's the honor, well I
guess it's better to go fast
than to go slow.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I grew up in New Orleans.
- On top of COVID,
having all of this.
- Right, that's not we
- Anyway, I love,
I really admire your work,
and I'm really,
I was really excited to
have this conversation,
so thank you.
- No, likewise.
And clearly, the hurricane
is only one thing
(laughing) that's going on in
everyone's lives right now,
as you just mentioned COVID
and obviously something that
you've been very central
in is the conversation around how schools
should, could reopen and what
are the supports we need.
So maybe a good place to start,
I just love to know where your head is.
What are you doing on a day-to-day basis,
And how are you thinking about
the school opening situation?
- So thank you for asking
the question that way.
So, I mean my head,
is kind of bursting
all the time right now.
Because this would be hard
regardless.
If you had good leadership in the country,
this would be hard.
With leadership that is incompetent
and
still denying COVID exists,
it makes it almost impossible
to try to figure out
how to get people the right information,
the science-based information
and how to keep communities safe.
And so I find it very frustrating.
I wanna scream most of
the time and I don't
because it's really important
to be heard right now.
And it's important to make sure
that people hear what
is accurate information,
even if they don't want to believe it.
So we started
thinking about how to
reopen schools safely
in the beginning of April.
Because we didn't wanna have
what happened in March happened again.
The haphazard way that
schools were closed,
our view was,
we were gonna learn as
much as we possibly could,
from as many of the
world-renowned epidemiologists,
virologists, infectious
disease folks, as we could.
And we had the advantage
that we are the second
largest nurse union,
not simply the second largest
largest teacher's union.
So in April we put out a very,
we put out our first plan
about how do we open schools
and communities safely.
And we spent a lot of
time talking to people
before we did that,
including our own members,
including parents
and including all the the
scientist I just talked about.
We just put out another
one, an updated one
about a week or two ago.
But frankly, even though we
know a lot more about the virus,
the safeguards are basically the same.
You have to contain the virus
in a region.
You have to maintain that containment
by testing, tracing and isolation.
You have to have the school safeguards
that would prevent a virus
from spreading in the school,
which includes six feet
of physical distancing
and masks, cleaning and ventilation.
And that's on top of
reasonably accommodating
those who are high risk and
obviously washing our hands.
And you have to actually
have a way to pay for that.
And that's just on the safety side.
On the the wellbeing and
the instructional side,
we need to have a lot better way
of making sure remote
instruction can engage kids
in some ways like you
have done so successfully.
And we also need to really
focus on wellbeing issues,
on digital divide issues and
on food and nutrition issues.
So we've been trying to
do all of those things
at the same time in 3,500 locations.
- No, it's not an enviable task.
And I speak to a lot of
district superintendents
and administrators and teachers,
and everyone is in this really, really
difficult situation right now.
I know, and we'll get into a little bit
of some of the contentious points about,
should a school be open or closed,
and distance learning,
good, bad, et cetera.
But have you seen pockets
of people doing it well,
either at the district
level or at a state level?
- Yes, they're very, very quiet about it
because they don't want
people to follow them,
and they don't want, because
anyone who's doing it well,
knows that at any moment,
there could be a kid
or a teacher that tests
positive for COVID,
and then you have to
close down immediately
and you have to actually
go through all of the safety protocols
and then you pray that,
that people don't get sick.
And or don't get very, very sick.
So a lot of the places,
Like for example Newark,
had summer school.
I frankly pushed for places
to do some summer schooling
if they could, first and foremost,
because of the kids who really needed it,
who didn't connect well on
on the screens,
like you and I are having right now.
But also to do it in a very safe way,
and in a way where we could learn things.
And so in places like Detroit,
it didn't work very well.
But a place like Newark,
it worked pretty well.
Or praise like BOCES in Suffolk County,
Montana, it worked pretty well.
Now to me, what do I mean when
I say it worked pretty well?
It means one, there
were no negative cases,
there were no positive cases of COVID,
and kids came, teachers were there,
there were the safety measures in place.
That is wonderful,
but it's also lucky.
When I say Newark worked very well,
it's because there were a
couple of positive cases
and they handled it well.
And they closed the school,
they communicated with
parents and with teachers,
they made sure that people
got tests immediately,
and they made sure they did
everything that they could
to keep kids and to keep
their, keep educators safe.
And then before they reopened,
they did all the kind of protocols,
including cleaning and everything
and contact tracing to make sure that,
that everybody who was in contact
with the person who tested positive,
they had gotten in contact with,
and those people were isolating.
So that's the kind of
thing that you have to do.
If you have like what has happened
in Gwinnett County in Georgia,
you see 240 people testing
positive in the first few days,
that is a big problem.
That is an SOS.
That means you gotta have
a different structure.
That's not close the school, close a pod,
see what happens.
That means you've got
too much community spread
in that community, and you need
to be on remote instruction
because school should not
be open in that situation.
So we're seeing
with both summer school,
as well as the starting
of the school year,
places that are doing it well
and places that are doing it badly,
but we also don't have the
resources from Washington yet,
which we need very badly.
And we also have a president who has been,
who is breeding chaos
instead of responsibility.
This is the moment that you
need to be really responsible,
not chaotic.
And his recklessness is
actually hurting things.
I'll give you one example.
In June, we polled our members.
And remember, this was before
you saw this huge escalation
in the South and Southwest.
And 75% of them said,
that if we could get the safety safeguards
that we were advocating for,
they were comfortable with
going back to school buildings.
Because they knew, how important
it was and it is for kids,
not just for feeding and
not just for wellbeing,
but for instruction as well.
And so that, if I polled
my members right now,
you'd see the exact reverse.
- And you see the reverse because
they don't have confidence
that some of the precautions
that you mentioned in the Newark place,
like the Newark context,
that those are in place,
that's where the fear is?
- I would say you'd see
it for four reasons.
One, because of the
huge increase in spread
in the South and Southwest.
Even though this week, you seem to have,
we have 14 states that are
hotspots rather than 18 States,
You still have 40 States,
where you see the line going like this,
as opposed to going like this.
That is now
and that's number one.
Number two, you have a
president who is a denier.
So yesterday he got on TV and said,
everything is going well,
even though Dr. Birx the day before,
said that things are really,
my words not her words.
Her words were
things were really
spreading very extensively.
So number two is the
president's recklessness.
Number three, is that there's been
a lack of resources from Washington.
So number four, the
planning that's been done,
is still in many, many
places, very, very vague,
because they planned hybrid,
but there's not a whole lot of,
meat behind,
there's not a lot of muscle
behind that planning.
- If I'm understanding you correctly,
I mean, it makes a lot of sense.
I'm just trying to think
through it logically.
If you're in a part of the country
that has low community spread,
it can have some spread,
but low community spread,
but it seems like it's in control.
Then open up in a very careful way,
have your contact tracing,
have the social distancing,
have the ventilation and keep track.
And as soon as the contact tracing
traces contacts within a school,
you do have to shut down,
which makes all the sense in the world.
- Right.
- And in places where
you have high community spread,
there's no point in trying to be physical
because you're very quickly
going to trigger a situation,
and you're gonna just
exacerbate the scenario.
So that to me
- Yeah.
- feels like a very reasonable,
I mean logical I don't,
somehow this is, it does feel
like it's gotten politicized.
When you look at the media,
it seems like there's
these kind of polar camps.
One is kinda open schools no matter what,
and one is don't open
schools no matter what.
And I'm definitely not
hearing that from you.
- No, and it's different.
Look we have 50 States,
we have 98,000 schools,
we have 16,000 school districts.
We've never had a one size
fits all for schooling
ever on virtually anything.
So why would you do it on
the most complicated things
that have affected America
in probably 100 years?
We haven't had a pandemic
like this in 100 years.
So that's why I'm saying,
but I think that the reason
we have this polar opposite,
is because, and I'm sorry that I'm blaming
the political leadership so much,
but they deserve to be blamed.
I don't believe we would have,
I don't believe this is a
Republican or Democratic issue.
I do not believe Margaret
Spellings would had been,
like Betsy DeVos
if she was the Secretary
of Education right now.
I know Arne Duncan wouldn't be,
he's been on TV a lot
and said this is crazy.
We would have, what would have happened,
with any normal Republican government
or Democratic government would
be what happened in Europe,
which is here's an emergency,
you bring stakeholders together,
district superintendents,
chief school officers, principals,
teachers, parent groups,
PTA, and you bring them together
under the auspices of the
Secretary of Education,
way back in April.
And you come up with guidepost
about how to do remote learning.
Just like you have done so well,
just like we did with capstone projects,
and we have done with our
platform, Share My Lesson.
But you socialize this, and
I don't mean it politically.
You, you do socialize it, you broaden it,
you communicate it through the country,
and you do it through the
Department of Education
as guidance.
And then you do the same exact thing
in April and May and June,
in terms of the preparing
for the next year.
So that districts had some
guidance about what to do.
Instead, we're still having
this bizarre conversation
about whether or not COVID is dangerous.
Yes, COVID is dangerous.
Yes, it's killed over 156,000 people.
Yes, we have four, one,
we have over 4 million cases right now.
This is a pandemic.
The fact that the President
and the Secretary of Education,
don't actually say that
over and over again,
is completely unconscionable.
Thank God younger children
are more resilient than everyone else,
and thank God, they don't
seem to get as sick as others.
And thank God we've had enough
therapeutics and other things
so that people who are testing positive,
who are getting sick right now,
who are on ventilators right
now, many of them get well.
But the fact that there is,
that there's any dispute
about whether or not
this virus is dangerous,
that is part of a lack of
credibility and the lack of trust
that's making our work much harder
because of the polarization.
- No, I mean this is
incredibly difficult for,
I can imagine.
A couple of questions,
I definitely want to get
to the instructional side of things,
and how can teachers and
families navigate this,
there's a ton of questions
that are coming in
through social media.
- Yeah.
- But just to stay on this
kinda the logistics question
and also to kind of understand
how this might play out,
I've also heard alternative solutions.
You touched on this notion
that potentially you're five, six, seven,
maybe eight-year-olds don't
necessarily spread the virus
or spread it as much,
are there hybrid cases
where we bring those kids back?
In the tuberculosis epidemic,
almost 100 years ago,
people did things like outdoor schooling.
Are things like that on the table?
And then
- They should be.
- the second part of my question,
But what's happened is this,
political reality that many mayors face,
that schools have been used as childcare.
And instead of actually
having side-by-side childcare,
that's absolutely essential
as well right now.
And where people could do,
kids could have done remote education
while they were in childcare.
But we need, schools are not childcares,
schools are schools.
And so part of this is that
schools are used in normal times
for many purposes.
Yes, they are centers of community,
yes, they are about empowering kids,
yes, they need to be equitable,
yes, we need to make
them excellent for all.
But they are basically used,
they are relied on for so
many communal purposes,
and that's part of the problem right now.
So I do think if we looked
at the research today,
what we would be doing is what Israel did
in terms of its second take at it.
Which is you would open,
first off, you have to have
professional development,
which hasn't happened.
I'm lifting up the Massachuset example
because I think them pulling together
two weeks of professional
development for their teachers
at the beginning of this
year to really think through
how to use remote, how to use
hybrid, how to instruct kids,
because it's really different as you know,
instructing kids through a camera,
is very different than
instructing kids personally.
It's a different art, it's
a different engagement,
it's really different.
And it takes different skills,
and you have to do things differently.
So having that now, having
that kind of knowledge
and professional development
is very, very important.
The second piece that's important
is really trying to have
professional development
about where kids are right now,
because the anxiety level is huge.
Particularly in communities
that have been most affected.
COVID affects people
who are black and brown
more than affects people who are white.
It affects people who are poor
more than it affects people who are not.
And so we have to be mindful of the agita
that is, and the anxiety.
The same is true in terms of unemployment.
Unemployment is affected
people who are black and brown,
more than it's affected
people who are white.
And the same is true in terms of
all the reckoning that
we're doing right now
in terms of racial injustice.
So you have three kind of
crises that have careened into each other.
And so the wellbeing issues
and how we address that
with our kids are
really, really important.
So you have to have that
professional development.
But the second piece to your question Sal
which is really important Sal,
which is really important, sorry,
is that
knowing full well that younger kids
seem to have less,
or seem to have more resilience,
even though they can spread more,
or even though that
there's studies that say
that they are carriers,
they have more resilience,
you can actually start
having smaller hybrid models
or smaller pods
of 12 kids or so
with a teacher,
and do it with young kids.
And that seems like it's
been more successful,
both in Denmark, now in
Israel and in Germany.
So why don't we learn from that
and bring the younger kids
in, in that kind of way,
and keep the older kids either on hybrid,
or slowly have outdoor schools
with group sessions and things like that.
- So what you just said
sounds very, very reasonable.
I'm actually not getting this nuance
when I read newspaper articles,
when I'm watching the news.
Is this where the conversation is?
are people
- Yeah.
- have discovered is
this has gotten polarized
and people are just kind of,
we're not opening schools
- No.
- or we are opening schools.
- It is where the
conversation started to go
in,
I would say in late June.
I started seeing a lot of
much more robust,
thoughtful conversations.
But throughout July, since
Trump did his recklessness,
you have basically, he
interjected himself in this
and you have basically
the huge polarization
as a result of it.
Because all those Trumpster governors,
like the one in Georgia
and the one in Florida
and Arizona,
are not gonna do a thing
that he doesn't like.
And so they, instead of
being much more nuanced
about what we need to do
to actually help schools,
to help open school buildings responsibly
and gradually in a way that helps children
and doesn't endanger
children and teachers,
you would be doing it the
way I just talked about.
But if the goal is that you
have to get kids into schools
in a sardine like way
because their parents need to go to work,
or the goal is, you need to do this
because you wanna see the
employment numbers go up,
or your goal is, just to create a divide
because you think the teachers
unions are going one way
so you wanna show parents
you're gonna go another way,
and you're doing it politically.
So if those are all your goals,
you get to where you've gotten
to right now, which is chaos.
If your goal is, how do we actually help,
knowing full well we're in a pandemic,
get kids back to school safely
in a way that doesn't
endanger kids and teachers,
you would be starting with
professional development, remote,
and slowly bring kids in
using younger kids and
special needs kids first,
because there seems to
be much less transmission
for those kids.
- And they probably need the
physical experience the most.
To your point,
- Yes, that too.
- special needs kids.
There's so many questions
- That too.
- I wanna get to on the,
on the instruction and
professional development side
that you referred.
But just one last question on just kind of
how this is gonna play out,
I guess you could say
logistically or politically
over the next two, three weeks
as we get into the meat of back to school.
What is your prediction?
I mean it sounds like you are not,
you're not holding your breath,
that great things are gonna happen
in some of the states that
are going to kind of open
and I guess pretend
that things are normal.
But are you seeing pockets
where there's hope?
I mean,
- Yes, I am.
- you mentioned
Massachusetts, there's Newark.
What do you think is gonna look like,
if we were to have this
conversation a month,
what's our post-mortem of
the back to school season?
- So if you asked me a month ago,
I was much more optimistic
than I am right now.
And every time the president
tweets some foolishness,
I'm much less optimistic because
it creates the polarization
rather than having the conversation.
They're useless.
DeVos is useless, there's
no guidance from her.
We haven't had the resources that we need,
and we know states are
still laying people off
and they have had 20% budget cuts,
and we need millions
and millions of dollars
for PPE and cleaning
and all of these stuff.
So I feel, I'm glad that
they're negotiating this week.
But we need that, we need the
resources from Washington,
and we need Trump and
DeVos to shut their mouths.
If that happened,
I would say that
you'd see a lot of places
starting on remote.
I think that unfortunately,
because of the lack of resources
and because of the COVID increase,
you're gonna see a lot of places
starting on remote education.
And then slowly, with the
professional development,
with tackling the virus,
you'll start seeing,
school districts bring in,
the most at risk kids in a hybrid fashion.
I think that this notion
that they were gonna start
with every single child,
back on the day after labor day,
and that would be, and they
would gonna be able to do that,
every school district
that has attempted to do that initially
is now rolling back their plans.
- And obviously,
- And part of it,
Let me just say, so part of it
is what has happened in
Gwinnett County in Georgia,
and what's happened in Indiana
and also what's happened
in terms of summer school.
Summer school places did
some of this very slowly,
and a couple of places
did it well like Newark
and a couple of places like Detroit,
had real outbreaks
and there was real
consternation as a result of it.
And when I say Newark did it well,
I mean there are places
like there's places like,
there's places like BOCES
on Eastern long Island
where, knock wood, they had summer school,
they had a very small summer school.
They had summer school, they
didn't have a case of COVID,
they didn't have a positive case.
That, I would say that's luck.
Because when I say Newark did it well,
it's because if you have a positive case,
it's a matter of how you deal with it,
how you create trust
and how you actually do
the work you have to do to,
to shut down the school,
make sure it's communicated
that there's a positive case,
make sure you make sure that
that you do the contact tracing,
so that you isolate everybody
who was in contact with that person.
And Newark did that well, and it created
it created some credibility.
But think about what's going on.
We spent all this time
talking about logistics,
and how little time talking about
what we need to do in
terms of instruction,
whether it's hybrid or
whether it's on remote.
- No, absolutely.
And one last question on the logistics,
because the instruction
is at least as important in this world.
Obviously when you read the headlines
especially with the last few weeks,
this notion of potential strikes,
have at least been surfaced.
If I'm, based on our conversation so far,
I'm perceiving that what you're saying is,
strikes where there are not precautions,
where community spread is so high,
that it would be just
fundamentally unsafe.
to send someone into that.
- Correct.
- Is that what y'all are advocating?
- How y'all thinking
about that?
- Right, the word in front of
strike, was the word safety.
Safety, strikes and labor have
a very particular meaning.
And they are only a last
resort if you can't do,
if you can't make it
safe in any other way.
We feel that we are now the
conscience of the country,
of making sure our kids, our communities
and our educators are safe.
And the fact that others are reckless,
makes us need to be more responsible.
Like no one got into teaching
to be a safety monitor.
And I'm a social studies
teacher and a lawyer.
So learning all this about,
learning all of the science,
was hard for me to learn.
But you have to learn it
in the middle of a pandemic
and you have to have those guardrails.
And I have to look at a lot
of people straight in the eyes
and say that in order to advise
that a school building should reopen,
that the kind of things that are done
to prevent virus spread are in there.
And if they're not in
there, I in good conscience,
cannot advise that a
building should reopen.
It doesn't mean
that there's not gonna
be a COVID positive case.
But we need to make sure, that
everything we can do is done.
That's what hospitals do.
That's what nursing home should have done.
And we need to do that
for schools as well.
We know what we need to do.
Those and yes, it's a
logistical challenge,
but if others refuse to do it,
that's why you have unions.
That's why you have collective bargaining.
That's why you have collective Goodwill.
Sometimes you have to take
the more responsibility
to make sure that things
are safe for people,
- Right, it is, well and to kind of
the most fundamental purpose of unions,
which is workplace safety.
- Right.
- Which, and this isn't
some blanket statement that
no school openings at all.
- It's only when,
- No.
- it's unsafe.
- Exactly.
And frankly that's why even
at our convention last week,
somebody raised that motion.
We had a virtual convention,
we had resolutions,
and there were two or three resolutions
where people tagged on a motion that says,
"We will not reopen schools
unless the virus rate is zero,
"or unless there is a vaccine."
And those motions were
rejected by my membership.
We know that there is not
a zero risk situation here.
We know that that kids
need in-school schooling.
Teachers would tell you that,
pre-pandemic they would have said,
"We need to see our kids,
"we need to have smaller class sizes
"and remote instruction
doesn't work very well,
"Sal Khan notwithstanding."
That's what people would have said.
Now they'll say it even more.
But it has to be safe.
Because if it's not safe,
then what ends up happening,
is a school outbreak,
could end up reinfecting
the entire community.
And so places like New York
and New Jersey and Connecticut,
that went through those sacrifices,
that the businesses that
didn't reopen early,
why would we put them through this again,
after all the work that they have done?
We have to educate our kids,
but we have to make it safe.
- No, that makes sense.
I mean my wife and I
were talking about it.
She's a physician
and even she works for
the County hospital.
She's a rheumatologist, so
she's not a pulmonologist.
She's not one of the
frontline workers here.
But for the rheumatologists, they are two.
They're making sure that
they have all the PPE,
patients that they can
see remotely they are,
the patients that they
absolutely have to see,
the precautions are
incredible that they're taking
with the monitoring,
the temperature checks,
the PPE, et cetera.
And then if you didn't have those,
my wife did not have those precautions
as a healthcare professional,
I would not encourage her to to show up.
My mother-in-law lives with us.
I mean it's just
- Yeah.
- for the safety of the community.
I mean going into the instructional side,
which as we've both been alluding to,
we've been so focused on
logistics, the whole world has
that the teacher training
the PD days, et cetera,
there's a lot of questions coming in.
I'll try to give a
synopsis of some of them.
This is a question from
a teacher on Facebook.
Randi will remote learning
make teachers obsolete,
will it damage the profession?
And then from Facebook,
Sara Jobin is asking,
what kind of student engagement
through remote learning
is actually working?
So what does good distance learning
look like?
- Yeah.
- Even you were very kind
when you said Khan Academy.
But I think it's working,
even Khan Academy in certain places,
I think some places it's
not working optimally
because they're not
getting enough supports,
the teachers aren't
getting enough support.
So I'd love your frame on
what should that professional development
look like for teachers?
- Right.
- What does at least decent
distance learning look like?
- So all kids are different
and all ages are different.
So again, there's not a one size fits all
in terms of distance learning.
But for the teacher who
raised that question,
I think that this, that we have now,
that the pandemic has now proven
that distance learning is a
supplement not a substitute
for in-person teaching and learning.
That the alchemy that happens in a class,
the engagement in-person
is really, really important for kids.
But it can be a supplement,
and ultimately right now,
I see this year as a bridge year.
We're in the middle of a pandemic.
Just like with TB, just
like what's the Spanish flu
of a hundred years ago,
just like with polio,
they have to take these things seriously.
And then we have to catch,
we have to help kids
feel confident that they will
be able to achieve regardless.
And then as these things
subside, or we get a vaccine,
or we get therapeutics like in AIDS,
we don't have a vaccine and
AIDS, but we have therapeutics.
We're able, you can see what has happened
in terms of the LGBTQ community,
in terms of what happened in the aftermath
of having the therapeutics,
in the late 80s early 90s.
What I think we have to do
in terms of instruction,
this is what I've seen work.
And frankly, it's just
from talking to people
who have done it over the course
of the last several months.
Number one, we have to be mindful
of how much screen time people have.
We also have to make sure
that there's real group instruction.
Asymmetric learning can
actually really work,
but schedules are really, really
important for younger kids.
And when I say asymptomatic
learning can work,
high school teachers have said to me,
that they could actually tape a lesson
and then use screen time
to reinforce that lesson.
You can use, I'm a big believer
in getting some tents up
and having some open air classrooms
in parks in September and October
and doing small group
instruction that way,
just like some
parents in well-off communities
are thinking about hiring a teacher
and doing a pod in that way.
But for younger kids, direct
instruction like this may work,
but you cannot be on a screen
for more than 45 minutes
at any particular time.
Kids have to be off the screen,
they have to be able to engage
in their own kind of learning,
and we have to figure out
how we get kids together
in some way, form or fashion
to stop the social isolation.
In terms of older kids,
I think you flip it.
You can actually do direct instruction
asynchronisticly if you want to,
you can just like with college kids,
you can tape a lecture.
But then you really need the group work
to reinforce or to create some alchemy.
And that's, but just like you
have done so much work Sal,
in this, we have Share My Lesson,
we have unprecedented numbers of people
who have joined Share My Lesson.
We make it for free for
everyone, for parents,
for kids, for teachers.
And so, and every day we
put tricks of the trade up.
The other thing I think is,
you could do things like using TV,
Fox in Washington DC,
would have like an hour
where it was dedicated every morning to,
to a different lesson by a
different master teacher.
You saw that in
California as well in the spring.
I think that lectures from the masters,
finding ways to have
really interesting content,
is gonna also be really important.
Doing things in a way where
families can come together.
I love the fact that we had
Lin-Manuel at our convention.
I love that Disney decided to put that on,
on air around July 4th weekend.
Having a family watch "Hamilton,"
and then you doing some kind of,
group instruction follow-up,
and you could do it with the whole family.
You make it a family enterprise
as opposed to kids being isolated.
Or you can do what some people,
some families have done this summer.
Which is they have a pod in the backyard,
or you could do it in the middle of,
within a housing project,
in the middle of the lawn,
in the middle of the housing project.
So we need to really kinda
think about different ways
of getting together,
having that engagement,
using the screen for certain things
and reinforcement for other things,
dependent upon pedagogically
where kids are.
- That makes a ton of sense
and rhymes or in some ways
it's exactly what I think what
we've been trying to advocate
very, very similar things.
You can have asynchronous learning,
obviously tools like Khan Academy.
There's other tools out there
where kids can get practice,
feedback, teachers can monitor.
But then the necessity of
having some form of whole group
synchronous community
building, I loved your ideas,
especially if you could figure out
ways that you could do it in-person,
somehow at a park and smaller groups,
but at least have some time.
But what I was hearing is 45,
you don't wanna stretch of more
than 45 minutes on a screen.
It's just bad for the eyes and the brain.
I think that's true
for adults as well.
- Yeah, I agree.
- But obviously just, make
sure there's breaks in there,
but kids feel like they're
part of a community.
Is there some baseline recommendation?
I've seen, in the spring we
saw versions was just like,
here's a couple of links
to some virtual schools
that are doing everything asynchronously,
which doesn't seem like a great experience
based on what you just described.
All the way to, I've seen some schools
that have been doing
everything you just described.
What's kind of a, a
minimum viable experience
in your mind
(laughing)
that at least parents and
teachers should strive for?
- So at the end of the
last year, we thought,
we were very big believers
in capstone projects
done in a developmentally appropriate way.
I mean you're not gonna
have a fourth grader
write a PhD project
on Lincoln and the Gettysburg Address.
And why did that not actually,
eliminate, eradicate racism in America?
That's not gonna be what
a fourth grader does,
but it could be what a 12th grader does
and 11th grader does.
And we've seen in terms
of portfolio schools,
how they were actually very adept,
at being able to move to remote
because of the kind of
guidance they had done
in terms of critical thinking
and group work and things like that.
So at the end of last year we thought
capping off, capping off
what people had done,
kids had done during the
year was really important
and we call the capstone projects.
In terms of the beginning of the year,
I would actually say as a bottom line,
wellbeing and community building,
and that the children will be okay,
it's gonna be most important.
Pam Cantor,
who leads turnaround schools,
the turnaround for children,
said something to us
at a town hall we did with
the PTA in March or April.
And she said,
a calm mind
will be a learning mind.
We have to make sure we reach
kids and we create confidence
and calmness that there'll be okay.
And that means that the wellbeing issues
become really important
and the engagement issues
become very important
as a pathway to getting to instruction.
- I wanna doubly underline that last part.
And people might even be
surprised hearing it from me,
'cause Khan Academy is
very much focused on,
"Dude, have you learned
this math or the science
"or this humanity standard?"
But I couldn't agree with you more
on what you just said that,
so many people right
now are so focused on,
"Oh, what if my kids don't learn
"to factor polynomial on time?"
Well yeah, that is an issue.
But if their mental health,
if their friendships,
if their connectedness,
if their confidence
somehow atrophies or dies
through this process,
then we have a much
bigger problem.
- Yup, yup.
- And how do you address that?
If we have to be distanced,
if we can't figure out the
logistics of meeting in a park.
Is it, you need at
least 30 minutes on Zoom
together with your friends and teachers.
What does that minimum
situation look like?
There's another question
from YouTube Susanna Garcia Dominguez,
do you think students have to have
the same number of hours
in online learning?
Is it nearly six hours?
- No.
- What is that,
- No,
I think that some of this,
we're gonna learn.
We're trying to create this box.
Like, okay we have to figure out 180 days.
Okay, we have to figure
out X number of hours.
Okay, if we don't do this
what is gonna happen?
We're in the middle of a pandemic!
Can we actually, if we could try.
So yes, I know I'm basically saying
the rules have to be rewritten.
The rules have to be rewritten right now.
The pandemic isn't over.
When it's over, we can actually figure out
what we need to do moving forward.
But just like you said, if
we don't actually create
confidence and engagement for kids,
if kids are socially isolated,
why are the pediatricians,
including my sister,
who is an intensive care pediatrician
at Montefiore hospital,
why are they constantly saying,
"The kids, look at the kids,
"Look at the social isolation,
"look at the fact that kids
who are not on digital,
"look at kids that need grab-and-go's."
Maslow comes before Bloom
any day of the week.
And we have to make sure that
we meet kids primal needs.
That has to be our job.
And if we do and we create confidence,
we're gonna get to the
other instructional pieces.
And so that's why, I know
all these states today
what are we gonna do with all our rules?.
I am focused on how do
we help start school
in a meaningful way, for
kids and for their teachers
who are in some ways their lifeline
to the next, to their dreams.
So is there a minimum?
I don't know what the minimum.
We're just, we have a
lot of practices now.
I don't think we can say
we know what's best yet,
because they haven't been tested.
What we do know is that
just like with adults,
if kids end up having like a
Zoom dinner with their friends,
just like, my friends and I, we have,
sometimes we'll have a Zoom drink.
Or in the midst of the New York shutdowns,
we'd have a Zoom drink together.
We'd have a Zoom dinner together.
We'd get together in that kind of way.
Not more than 45 minutes or an hour
because of the same reasons.
But I do think we have to find
a way to get kids together.
And that creating these kinds of pods
that families are doing,
creating ways of getting kids together
in a socially appropriate
way, wearing masks,
being physically distant
is very, very important.
And if we can do that
in terms of schooling,
if we can use even a school building,
even if we're doing remote
and we have like a Saturday
afternoon walk with our kids,
that will be important.
But that's gonna, we're
gonna learn more and more,
but the point is, it's important
for people to get together,
and to see each other
and to be in community with each other.
- No couldn't agree more.
And the time has gone by
way faster than I expected.
I could talk to you for
another several hours.
There's so much, I
wanna learn from you on.
One kind of last question,
maybe to sum up everything.
- And I learnt, look, I've
been learning from teachers
and educator and
paraprofessionals and bus drivers
and guidance counselors.
We've basically really taken
in all the learning from people
all throughout the last several months
in terms of what has
worked and what hasn't.
- No, absolutely.
I mean based on that,
based on all of these
data points you've seen,
if we're talking a year from now,
I'd love to know kind of
both of your hopes and fears.
The fears, what's kind of the,
this is clearly suboptimal
situation, on so many dimensions.
What's some of the things
that we're gonna have to
repair a year from now
and are there some silver linings?
Are there some things that
we might a year from now
come out a better for?
- So I'm an optimist.
So I always have to think
about a silver lining,
even in the midst of these three crises.
Look, so number one, we
have to fight the pandemic.
Truth is very important,
science is very important.
And those things, we need leadership
that will fight the
pandemic, that's number one.
And I think frankly,
even though the country is
very polarized right now,
more and more and more people see that,
and that is really important.
Number two, I think that out of this
will be a sense that public
schooling is really important
and the community building and people,
kids being together
in-person is very important.
And it's not simply the means of parents
who now
have a healthy respect
for that teaching
is both a science and
an art form and a craft
as well as a skill, but
that the whole alchemy
of having public schools is important.
And that remote can be a supplement,
but it's not a substitute.
Number three, I think that this gives
a new kind of movement builder to science,
and the importance of science.
And the importance of data
and understanding the world.
And understanding what
science means to the world.
Number four, I think it gives a sense
that we have to work on things equitably.
That in this pandemic,
just like so much else,
the people who have gotten
really, really hurt,
are the people who are most
at risk in normal situations.
And you see it in terms of
who's gotten the racial
health disparities.
You see how racism is really built
into so many of our structures in America.
And number five, I would
say that working families
and working people, are the
ones who have gotten us through
where we've gotten thus far.
The grocery workers, the nurses,
the doctors, the EMT folk.
The people who have
been on the front line,
actually making sure
that the rest of us got fed, got helped.
The teachers who made sure that
kids were engaged last year
or are trying to figure out right now.
And so this has not been as important as
a President is supposed to be,
or a big media star is supposed to be.
This has been everyday
people and governors
in many states, who have
really gotten us through this.
So those are kind of
silver linings that I see.
I think if we can create a confidence,
that dreams will not be,
dreams may be deferred
for a minute or two,
but we can get the economy back
after the virus is tackled.
I think if we, if we get
a sense of confidence
that we can fight the virus,
and confidence that America
can pull itself up again,
like it did in the recession,
the Great Depression,
then I think we will be able
to meet the needs of our kids.
But if we don't fight the virus
and if we don't make sure people are safe,
then I'm very fearful for the future.
- Yeah, well Randi thank you so much.
I mean this was an
incredible conversation.
As I said, I could keep going.
But I know in this time
to have any time with you is a real honor
and I think you've really helped
a lot of the folks watching
understand all of the issues
that play a lot better,
so thank you so much.
- Thank you, thank you for everything.
- So thanks everyone for
joining today's conversation.
Obviously we went over,
my apologies to Randi,
I probably kept her longer
than we originally promised,
but I thought there was
just too much to talk about.
Frankly there's more
(laughing) I would like to.
But I got a couple of very
powerful takeaways there.
Obviously safety first, we're
in the middle of a pandemic.
What I heard is, what I
thought made a lot of sense is,
when you can create safe environments,
and let's be creative about
creating safe environments,
with ventilation with maybe
it's the younger kids,
maybe it's not a full
day, whatever it might be.
You meet up in the park,
those are reasonable options.
But when community spread is very high,
we kind of have to hunker down
as a little bit of society.
And I also heard on
the instructional side,
let's not try to do
everything for everyone.
That'll just create a lot of stress.
And it's frankly an unrealistic goal,
we're in the middle of a pandemic.
Try to focus on the basics
and the most basic of basics
is kind of the Maslow's hierarchy,
people feeling safe and secure
and part of a community.
And if they have that, if
their mental wellbeing is good,
their social wellbeing is good,
then we can start to build up on that.
And once again we don't
have to do everything.
But if we can get some
of those core skills
of math, reading and writing,
make sure they don't atrophy,
make sure we have some progression,
that we're gonna be holding
the fort reasonably well
when it comes to education.
So thanks everyone for joining
and thanks for your great questions.
I will see you, I'm
actually going on a mini,
a much needed camping trip tomorrow.
But I will see you next week.